you know the pandemic forced a lot of
folks to put their las vegas wedding
plans on hold
however the number of marriage licenses
being issued now
we're told it's almost back to the
levels they were before the pandemic
that looks like pirate captain bowtie
hector mejia live on the las vegas trip
to explain how the wedding industry is
helping folks walk the plank to the ball
and chain of eternal bliss
hector hey there nate good morning so
yeah i am
half pirate half groom this morning you
know when i was a child and i would
watch the pirate show from way back then
it was one of my dreams to
be on the ship and now here i am and not
only am i just walking here along the
ship
but i'm also wearing one of the actual
costumes that they use for the weddings
now and joining us live we have joanne
joanne tell us all right so this is cool
thank you so much for having us
thank you i'm glad to be here so tell us
how does this costume
play a role in the weddings out here
well right now you could be an efficient
overseeing a wedding and pronouncing a
couple
that's really cool and so weddings right
now you were telling me you guys are
seeing a big demand for them
we are weddings are up as you've
discussed this morning
we're seeing a lot more
need for larger weddings which is a good
thing we started out at like 15 and 20
at the beginning of the pandemic and now
we're looking at more of groups of 100
and that's exciting so with restrictions
you know getting a little easier
that only means that you guys are
already seeing the interest in larger
weddings happening
and why is it so heartwarming i mean you
see this every single day
every day well every couple has a story
that's true so
now that people are you know they're
coming back to vegas they're getting
together
you're hearing these wonderful stories
you're seeing happiness it's just a
really fun great job to do
and it's also interesting to highlight
you were also sharing with me that
you know right after the closures people
were called back
specifically for the wedding industry
here on the las vegas stream
they were there was still a demand for
weddings and of course you have to have
people to operate those weddings and as
we're growing we're going to start
calling more and more people back you're
going to need them
to cover the demand and besides the ship
around there's also one just on the
other side tell us about
that being featured in hollywood well
that is the bullship
and that was most known for miss
congeniality too
william shatner and sandra bullock they
were underneath and he was trapped and
she went to go save them so
that's a really if you haven't seen it
it's a really cool part of the movie
thank you for having us joanne so
there's a plank here
so for those who were planning on
getting married and somewhat
somehow got some cold feet there's a
plank there and um
you know this is just really cool this
is where they have the wedding and where
the couples
say i do but i'm here all by myself so
i'm just going to stick around for a few
and i'm going to send things back over
to you guys reporting live
from treasure island hector mejia 8 news
now back to you
all right hector i'm sure someone will
come along and have something to say to
you
but great job reporting on the rise of
the wedding industry
john alex